when we think about the civil rights
movement in the United States most
people immediately think of Martin
Luther King jr. and almost everyone can
recite the beginning of his either dream
speech but the story of another human
rights activist Malcolm X is often
censored in history class he is
misunderstood as someone he preached
hate and violence against white people
and some believe that if young people
watched his speeches it could actually
be rather dangerous because of that his
memory is often swept under the rug
while everyone knows him by name not
enough people know the true story of
Malcolm X he was one of the most
influential Americans who ever lived and
his legacy still echoes on to this very
day without him the US and maybe even
the entire world would be a really
different place in today's bio graphics
we're gonna talk about the incredible
life of Malcolm X a boy named Malcolm
little was born on May the 19th 1925 in
Omaha Nebraska he was one of seven
children belonging to Louise and a
little now his parents taught their
children all about the history of
slavery and the importance of rising
above their circumstances now can his
siblings they were all extremely well
behaved even from a young age because
they knew that they were trying to
represent their race in a positive light
his father
Earl believes in the teachings of a man
called Marcus Garvey a black nationalist
leader who preached that African
Americans should be self-sufficient when
it came to running their own farms and
their own businesses L was a Baptist
minister who pushed for desegregation
between white and black people because
of this their family received death
threats from the KKK on a daily basis so
they were constantly moving just to stay
alive in 1929 Earl little bought his
family a four acre farm in lansing
michigan which had a very good
neighborhood with great schools the only
issue was that they were the only black
family in town now hate isn't something
that children are born with so Malcolm's
classmates in kindergarten treated him
just like everyone else
Malcolm's favorite game was Robin Hood
and he always invited his friends over
to run through the fields and the
forests of his family farm pretending to
steal from the rich and give to the poor
eventually the racist members of the
community they caught winds of this
black family living a comfortable
middle-class life and I didn't like it
the neighbors complained saying that
black evil should not be allowed to own
so much land even though there was no
law saying that they couldn't live there
the local council voted on the issue and
agreed that the little family had to
move l-little refused to leave saying
that his family had every right to stay
there
lansing michigan was home to an offshoot
of the KKK called the Black Legion
instead of wearing silly white robes
with pointed hoods they dressed up and
even sillier pirate costumes you really
couldn't make these things up one night
the little family awoke to an explosion
as these white supremacists held bombs
of their house Merlin Louise had to wake
up the children and get them to safety
despite the explosions which could
certainly be heard from Mars local
firefighters think never showed up to
help and the house it burned to the
ground in the morning l-little
confronted the local police he accused
them of being members of the Black
Legion the police responded by arresting
him fast and saying that he burned down
the house to receive an insurance
settlement the charges though they were
later dropped even after this they
refused to leave because they wanted to
be an example of the black family who
stood their ground and didn't give up
without a fight unfortunately their
strength and resolve it was not enough
to convince the citizens of Lansing that
they were worthy of living there when
Malcolm was just six years old Earl's
body was found crushed on the tracks of
a streetcar the coroner ruled it an
accident the police said that he
committed suicide in his autobiography
Malcolm X explains that his father had
sustained injuries not consistent with a
street car accident
despite the coroner's statements the
insurance company that held earl littles
policy refused to pay Louise due to
their contention that Earl's death was a
suicide
Malcolm's mother had a very difficult
time raising her eight children alone
she sold many of their belongings and
would so for people in town in order to
make an income she rented their lands
other local farmers but there was never
enough money to go around she was a
proud woman though she lived by a
principle since she never asked for a
handout from anyone the family they soon
had to go on welfare but as the years
went on the weight of the responsibility
continued Terra Huerta Louise knew that
the white people in town they hated her
and that the men responsible for her
husband's death they were living close
by she was constantly afraid that
someone would come after her and her
children even though her fears were
completely justified she was diagnosed
as paranoid and that local police
committed her to a mental institution
Malcolm was 13 when his mother was taken
away and he under six siblings were
split up and sent to orphanages and
foster homes they kept in touch by
writing letters to one another and swore
that they were all reunite again someday
despite all of these setbacks Malcolm
still had a lot of ambition for himself
and he never forgot the lessons that his
parents taught him in the eighth grade
he was a straight-a student and at the
top of his class he was intelligent
charismatic and he had a passion for
public speaking when he went to high
school he joined the debate team and
continued earning a 4.0 GPA one of his
teachers asked everyone what they wanted
to be when they grew up and Malcolm said
that he wanted to become a lawyer the
teacher said that this was impossible
saying that black people were simply not
allowed to be lawyers his teacher
further responded one of life's first
needs is for us to be realistic you need
to think of something you can be why
don't you plan on carpentry in reality a
man named Malcolm V Allen had already
become America's first black lawyer in
the 1800s but of course Malcolm could
not have known that he believed his
teacher was right he was still living in
foster care and he no longer had his
mother and father to encourage him
despite being a straight-a students he
thought that as a black person there
truly was no point in continuing at
school he dropped out in order to begin
working and start a new life when he was
Malcolm moved to New York City to live
in Harlem he got a job doing dishes at
restaurants and his charismatic
personality helped him make a lot of
friends of all races why men began to
approach him asking if he had any drugs
or if he could hook them up with black
girls since people were already making
that assumption based on stereotypes he
decided that he might as well take
advantage of it
this started his successful side hustle
of being a pimp a robber a racketeer and
a drug dealer he befriended John Elroy
Sanford a fellow dishwasher at Jimmy's
Chicken Shack in Harlem who aspired to
be a professional comedian both men had
reddish hair so Sanford was called
Chicago red after his hometown and
little was known as Detroit red yes
later
Sanford became famous as red fox one
littles best friends was a teenage boy
who shared his first name Malcom Jarvis
the two of them they hustled together
and they would go out to jazz clubs at
night they were suit
and impress the ladies with their dance
moves for a while they were raking in a
loss of money and having the time of
their lives
in 1949 the two Malcolm's were both
dating white girls who they met at a
nightclub
these girls had very rich parents and
they were bored cut to maniacs
looking for a bit of excitement they
encouraged the Malcolm's to form a
Bonnie and Clyde star gang together they
would let the boys know whenever their
parents neighbors were on vacation and
then they would all go and steal from
their homes together Malcolm must have
felt that he was playing a grown-up
version of Robin Hood but when the group
was caught it caused a huge outrage in
the courts because of their mixed races
no one could believe that two rich white
girls could have possibly been the
masterminds behind the robberies and of
course their parents could afford to get
them lawyers so the girlfriends lied
under oath claiming that they didn't
even know the boys and that they had
been kidnapped and forced to participate
in the robbery both Malcolm's were only
twenty years at the time and they both
received the maximum sentence of 8 to 10
years in prison the women were able to
walk free without any punishment when he
was in prison
Malcolm realized that many black men
were totally innocent and had been
falsely accused of crimes these innocent
men they turned to God in order to cope
with their fate this made Malcolm very
angry he had become a staunch atheist
because he believed that if there were
truly a god he wouldn't let black people
suffer like they were suffering he
yelled at other inmates being stupid
enough to believe in God and claims that
even if he did exist he had abandoned
black people completely an elder inmate
John Bembry could see that he was very
angry and in a lot of pain so he told
Malcolm that if he could not escape
through religion he should turn to books
instead because it could help transport
his mind to other places
Malcolm took this advice and began to
read every book in the prison library
for the first time in his life he was
reading Shakespeare and all of the other
great works and he truly did escape into
his own mind
after being in prison for some time one
of Malcolm's brothers wrote to him
explaining that his siblings had finally
reunited and they were attending
meetings of a group called the Nation of
Islam
Malcolm ripp bag that he did not believe
in any God but his brother promised him
that if he started praying to Allah he
would get out of prison early
his brother sent him a book written by
Elijah Muhammad who was the leader of
the Nation of Islam in his book Elijah
Muhammad wrote that black people were
already going through their own version
of hell on earth and that white men were
their demonic oppressors the Nation of
Islam as some of the traditional beliefs
of Middle Eastern Islam but it mostly
focuses on raising the confidence of
black people saying that they were
actually the superior race he encouraged
them to educate themselves become
self-sufficient and have pride in their
race this was basically the way that
Malcolm had been raised by his parents
and it was clear that Elijah Muhammad's
teachings paralleled those of Marcus
Garvey
Malcolm decided to give the Nation of
Islam the chance even though he had
never set foot in a mosque before he
started to grow his beard refused to eat
pork and prayed to Allah several times a
day the prison guards they tried to stop
him so he wrote to the governor
demanding that as an American citizen he
should have the right to choose his
religion so part of Elijah Muhammad's
teachings was to stop trying to please
or integrate into white society and take
pride in being an African American so
Malcolm dropped his last name little
which was given to his ancestors when
they were slaves as a sign of ownership
he had no idea what his family's real
African tribal name had been so he
decided to replace it with a simple X
representing the missing family history
that had been stolen from him he later
wrote for me my ex replaced the white
slave master name of little which some
blue-eyed devil names little that
imposed upon my paternal forebears now
that he went by Malcolm X II started a
debate team and the prison and men would
go to listen to him speak he was such an
amazing speaker that several other men
were convinced to drawing the Nation of
Islam and they began to pray together
instead of being meek and subservient to
the white guards they stood tall and
suddenly seemed far more confident and
powerful than ever before this made the
prison guards nervous they thought that
Malcolm X might have too much control
and that if he was released he would
incite riots and start a race war the
warden notified the FBI and he
placed on a watch list and denied parole
despite his good behavior he was finally
released from prison after six years and
he immediately became a minister for the
Nation of Islam in Detroit Michigan he
was so good at speaking that he was
given the position of national spokesman
when he first got started Elijah
Muhammad only had managed to gather 500
members into the Nation of Islam in the
United States in 1952 but once Malcolm X
toured and gave speeches it quickly grew
to over 30,000 members by 1963 Malcolm X
was constantly trying to build up the
confidence of African American people he
encouraged black people to feel proud of
their natural hair and their dark skin
and never tried to compare themselves to
white people he encouraged them to open
their own businesses in Harlem
barbershops butchers restaurants and
clothing stores owned by black people
sprang up for the very first time in
American history this sparked a trend
across the nation and black businesses
they became commonplace in all major
cities it was at this point that Malcolm
X met and fell in love with a woman
named Betty Sanders since the two they
got married they would go on to have six
daughters together
Malcolm started a fraternity group
called the fruit of Islam these were men
who were like a private militia they
were always clean-cut and war brand new
suits with pride they were disciplined
and he taught them to never use violence
and bless it was in self-defense after
all peaceful civil rights protesters
were being hosed down beaten by police
and attacked by guard dogs he believed
that if they wanted to get things done
successfully they needed to prepare for
the possibility that if they began to
fight for their rights it might cause a
war between black and white people the
fruit of Islam they were taught never to
attack first but they should not accept
a beating without fighting back
on April the 26th 1957 one of the
members of their congregation Johnson X
Henson was taking suits out of his car
in front of the Muslim temple in New
York City police officers saw this and
they accused him sin of stealing the
suits when he tried to explain that they
belong to the congregation they beat him
with heavy clubs and detained him in the
police station without giving him
medical attention Malcolm X he rushed to
the police station and ask to see
Johnson when they told him to leave he
told the officers to look out of the
window a line of men wearing crisp suits
sunglasses and fedoras were all standing
out on the streets
it was an entire army of the fruit of
Islam ready
from alkanes orders and they finally
agreed to let him see Johnson
Malcolm demanded that they call an
ambulance because he was bleeding
heavily and dying his injuries
the militia followed them all the way to
the hospital when it was confirmed that
Johnson would survive Malcolm waved his
hands and the militia dispersed
preventing what would have been a
massive riot this terrified the NYPD and
it was clear that even though they had
no idea who he was until that day he was
a very powerful man in New York City one
officer was quoted as saying no man
should have that much power he later
tried to sue the city to pay for
Hinton's medical expenses but they
denied everything
Malcolm X decided to travel across the
country and convert new people to the
Nation of Islam they eventually opened a
Muslim temple in Los Angeles in 1962 an
almost identical situation happened all
over again a man named Ronald Stokes was
taking the dry-cleaning out of a car in
front of the mosque the police accused
him of stealing the suits and when he
tried to explain he put his hands up and
they began shooting him at close range
11 men rushed to help their friends and
tried to pull the police officers away
but they were all arrested and they were
all accused of being part of a so-called
mob in the local newspaper it was
printed that this was a Muslim riot in
court the police officer who shot and
killed Ronald Stokes had mitad that he
knew that Stokes was unarmed but that he
shot him first because he raised his
hands in a menacing way in just 25
minutes the white jury decided that this
was enough justification to murder him
and the officer he was set free
immediately after this man got away with
murder
11 members of Nation of Islam were found
guilty of assaulting a police officer
and they were all sent to prison after
this incident Malcolm X realized that
the fight was too much for even the
Nation of Islam to handle he called for
all black people to come together
regardless of their religion in order to
fight for civil rights following Stokes
his death Malcolm X gave one of his most
famous speeches we are oppressed
we are exploited we are downtrodden we
are denied not just civil rights but
human rights so the only way we are
going to get some of this oppression and
exploitation away from us is to come
together against a common enemy
for years Malcolm X was the face of the
Nation of Islam and even though he was
spreading the teachings of his mentor
Elijah Muhammad the man rarely did any
of the work himself once a month Malcolm
would visit Chicago to give money to
Muhammad for his living expenses
one day he ran into three young women
who were knocking on Muhammad's door
they were demanding that he give the
money for food and child support he
learned from them that Elijah Muhammad
had cheated on his wife and had eight
children with six different secretaries
the girls were all only 16 or 17 years
old at the time so this was also
statutory rape he was not taking
responsibility for his kids and he had
ruins the lives of these young women now
have asked Elijah's son Wallace if this
was actually true and he admitted that
he and his mother knew but they were in
denial
the followers were so blindly faithful
to Elijah Muhammad's that even when the
word spread that the founder of the
religion was a liar and a hypocrite they
accused Wallace of lying about his
father
Muhammad confirmed the rumors in 1963
attempting to justify his behavior by
referring to presidents certify biblical
prophets Malcolm X did not leave Nation
of Islam right away though but he did
distance himself he focused more on
preaching about the civil rights
movements for a time he thought that he
had been tricked into living a lie since
he was struggling with his Muslim faith
Malcolm X took a pilgrimage to Mecca in
Saudi Arabia in 1964 he was shocked to
see people of all races making the
pilgrimage together Elijah Muhammad was
teaching that white people were evil but
once Malcolm saw what true Islam was
like he knew this was proof that
Brotherhood amongst the human race could
exist it seen it with his own eyes he no
longer believed that Martin Luther King
jr. was preaching a pipe dream he was
inspired to give himself a new name
Alhaji Malik el-shabazz he spent an
additional three weeks traveling around
to several countries in Africa when he
returned to the United States he was a
completely changed man
he no longer preached that white men
were Devils and he said that all people
needed to come together and live in
peace on March the 8th 1964 he announced
that he was leaving the Nation of Islam
and he exposed all of the corruption
that he had kept secret until then he
compared the religion to a mafia crime
ring this he no longer wanted to be a
part of he said that if anyone wanted to
follow him he was going to start up his
own Muslim group called
Muslim mosque Inc this was a huge threat
to Elijah Muhammad's livelihood of
course and I put a target on Malcolm's
back are you not perhaps afraid of what
might happen to you as a result of
making these revelations oh yes I
probably am a dead man already
Malcolm received death threats but he
kept moving and began traveling with a
newfound motivation to bring peace to
all nations
he became an international diplomats and
traveled to 14 African countries meeting
with 11 heads of state he wanted to
discuss the treatment of African
Americans and the human rights issues
that they were facing in America he
encouraged the United Nations to step in
to help black people in the United
States since he believed that the
American government were not doing
enough to support the rights of black
people the FBI and CIA they were
following him wherever he went and he
was receiving harassing phone calls on a
daily basis Elijah Muhammad told Boston
Minister Lewis acts later known as Louis
Farrakhan that hypocrites like Malcolm
should have their heads cut off and the
April 10th edition of Mohammed speaks
featured a cartoon depicting Malcolm X's
bouncing severed head his house in New
York
it was later firebombs and his wife and
daughters were very nearly killed
Malcolm X publicly announced that he
knew Elijah Muhammad had ordered a hit
on his life and that he was going to die
soon unfortunately it was right in 1965
Malcolm X was giving a speech in New
York City when a member of the Nation of
Islam shot him in the chest at close
range with a sawed-off shotgun two other
men fired semi-automatic handguns he had
21 gunshot wounds on his body he was 39
years old actor and activist Austin
Davis delivered the eulogy describing
Malcolm X's our shining black prince who
didn't hesitate to die because he loved
us so Malcolm X was only just beginning
his new goal of attempting to change the
lives of African Americans everywhere
there is no way of knowing just how much
he would have complet
was given that chance before his death
he had admitted that he had made a
mistake by preaching hate against white
people when he first got started and he
was ready and willing to go along with
Martin Luther King and the civil rights
movement if he was still alive today
there is no telling just how much more
he would have accomplished even in his
short time on earth he inspired African
Americans to be the people proud of
their skin color the
of him black people everywhere began to
demands more for themselves and from the
expectations of everyone in their
country no matter what religion someone
is subscribed to they can still find
inspiration from listening to his
speeches about human rights and whether
they know it or not there is so much in
American society that would have never
existed without the influence of Malcolm
X so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
just like this several days a week also
if you're looking for something else to
watch right now why not check out
another channel of mine called today I
found out you find that link to below
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]